un week-end sous la neige c'est ce que
les saint-quentinois ont pu connaître en
cette fin de semaine depuis samedi le
paysage a revêtu son plus beau manteau
la neige le week end une équation moins
problématique que les intempéries en
pleine semaine ainsi parents et enfants
s'en sont donné à coeur joie j'aime bien
la neige alors du mois fait une descente
ouais pourquoi fermer top
ou aller vite oui très sympa avec les
enfants avec les deux filles on profite
de ces contraintes temporelles on va
dire pour faire du un peu de luge qui
après ont frappé du ski de fond
java campe un copain pour pour aller
faire de la luge parfois on se gamelle
et parfois non
malgré les apparences ce n'est pas
forcément la descente la plus périlleuse
la montée elle aussi réserve quelques
surprises la neige s'est offert un
week-end prolongé sur le territoire
saint quentinois elle devrait laisser
place au verglas est à la pluie dans les
jours à venir mais les prochains flocons
reviendront très vite ils sont attendus
dès jeudi en novembre